okay Simpson could soon be a free man
and Nevada parole board will hear
arguments tomorrow about whether to
release the former football star from
prison Simpson is approaching the
nine-year minimum of his 33 year
sentence he was convicted in 2008 of
armed robbery and of the charges John
Blackstone is at Nevada's Lovelock
Correctional Center northeast of Reno
where Simpson is being held John good
morning good morning well this isolated
prison has been Simpsons home since 2008
he was convicted for taking part in a
incident in a Las Vegas hotel room in
which he was trying to retrieve items
that he claimed had been stolen from him
but many believe the harsh sentence in
this case was payback for another crime
the double murder in 1994 from which he
was found not guilty guilty count -
conspiracy to commit kidnapping guilty
this was the trial that put OJ Simpson
behind bars nearly a decade ago in 2007
grainy surveillance video from a Las
Vegas casino showed Simpson leaving a
sports memorabilia dealers hotel room
and heading back into the national
spotlight yes yes tom rish mee-o
arranged the meeting with dealers who
had items apparently stolen from Simpson
he made an audio recording of the
confrontation part of which was later
played in court
so that's Oh Jason don't let nobody out
of here yeah that one phrase from Oh
Jade don't let anybody into the room
that really got him convicted
that's what jurors said yeah I think
you're right yeah yeah they considered
that kidnapping when they say don't let
anybody out of here and the guys at the
pillowcases pulled out guns and turned
it into an armed robbery that's that's
why he's in jail today ratio was given
immunity and testified for the
prosecution
the Nevada jury found Simpson guilty of
not just kidnapping but also armed
robbery and assault with a deadly weapon
he was sentenced to a minimum nine years
in prison I am sorry for what is
happen he was last seen at a parole
hearing on lesser charges four years ago
I just wish I had never gone to that to
that room I wish have been I wish I had
just said keep it and not worry about at
that hearing the parole board ruled in
Simpsons favor but he was not released
retired prison guard Jeffrey Felix says
he befriended Simpson in Lovelock
and says he's been a model inmate he's
been in that prison for nine years
without one right up
he's helped other inmates with problems
I mean he's gotten in no trouble in nine
years that's very hard to do hojae's low
profile prison life stands in stark
contrast to his very high profile
brushes with the law which started in
1994 he surrendered to authorities after
leading police on a slow-speed chase
watched by millions on TV as was his
subsequent trial for the murders of his
ex-wife Nicole and her friend Ron
Goldman Paulin thought James Simpson not
guilty of the crime of murder the trial
lasted more than eight months the debate
about whether justice was served
continues to this day so he existed he's
not guilty
oh yeah he insists till today he didn't
do it you don't believe him
no I do not the parole board is not
allowed to consider the murder trial in
in its deliberations Thursday they will
look at Simpson's age and his behavior
in prison and legal experts say it's
likely he'll win release Norah we
interesting to see that decision John
thank you so much